bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su the
strange adventures che sarebbe un gioco
per ipad
stavolta non ci avevo la terra regala
bisognerebbe salvare questa principessa
si tratta non ha gran [ __ ] quindi non
vedo che bello che onda di qua ci avrei
scommesso guarda devo passarci sopra
praticamente credo è un ok allora
prefetto e allora sei punti non è
possibile che
ma che cazzo che ai venti volte più
difficile di quanto pensassi c'è una
roba
e allora [ __ ] per fare ma la
vediamo di capire cosa ho beccato
ovviamente non dai cat non c'era prima
c'è una chiave ragazzi credo che io
debba prenderla ma non è non ne sono
completamente invece sì che è successo
non sono morto è vabbè c'è certo ho
avuto l'illuminazione troppo tardi
ragazzi prova va bene così questo era il
check point credo un dvd e aiuta i
tumori fantastica la cabello che cosa
sono sti ragazzi [ __ ] sono sti
cosi allora se mi spari un altro razzo
su per il no in chiaro arrivato alla
fine no dai non avevo visto ok arrivo
[ __ ] se l'ho presa e l'ho presa dal
primo è andato legale è una trappola e
indica la leva perfetto allora io so che
questa è una trappola quindi non la
tocco però conoscendo questi giorni del
cazzo questa non è una trappola quindi
la tolgo invece era una trappola sono un
[ __ ] adesso ci siamo capite che non
avevo del tutto torto all'inizio
non del tutto io non lo devo cliccare su
una società deve andare senza dovevo
cliccarlo merda ma scusatemi nata abel
ha certo ma sicuro lo sapevo questo sì
sì l'ho preso fatto anche abbastanza in
fretta sinceramente quindi va bene così
vivi tu sei una [ __ ] ma forte sentite
una no si ok mi sono salvato per cui
nella maniera incredibile perfetto
perfetto guardalo no no non ci posso
credere
a parte tutto quanto questa è stata una
delle trovate migliori questo lo
riconosco è stato io già non ce la
faccio più ok ok se dopo essa ce la
fanno cisco sono tipo contenti cos'è sta
roba mi sembrano tipo che i tuoi che non
devo ammazzarli in 8 secondi
io sto facendo non ce la sto facendo un
cazzo faccio sono troppi non si può fare
in 8 secondi sto schifo ragazzo ma è
impossibile ragazza non si può fare in 8
secondi e assurdo ma non posso neanche
volendo non ci sono neanche non ci sono
abbastanza ballini perduta come penso
faccio no no è impossibile basterà frega
sì sì un rotolo logio non ci possono
line e mezz'ora che sono giusto per noi
non ci credono
lasciamo perdere che è meglio suo chiaro
su un volo mancavo anche toccami per
mostrare le trappole perfetto grazie
grazie
ci sarà una strada che prendo che è
quella giusta no evidentemente nokia
lancio live ad un altro buon ragazzi non
è positiva fonti sentite
adesso mi rompe di carlo ecco perfetto
ma perché era tragico per questo l'uomo
salta ma non mi incazzo
[Musica]
ma il bello è che quando pensi di fare
le cose giuste succede qualcosa che te
le fa sbagliare tipo questo zucca adesso
ci dovrei essere perfetta solo una roba
simile anche in cat mario qualcosa ce
l'ho fatta abbastanza in fretta
ok ok ok calmy rey ha tranquillamente
provo adesso arrivo alla fine arrivò
alla fine lo so io lo so che non devo
passare lì sotto sono convinto
minchia se ha ammesso non so che cosa
c'era lì sotto ma non voglio neanche
scoprirlo bisogna starci micari la
madonna mi fate partire si può partire
in salita o un cazzo è costata non si
può fare su schifo calmi in mano amica
mezz'ora la nuvola mi ammazzo con
convinto no
cazzo è successo dai cani che si stavano
i cenoni altri 20 minuti così credo di
aver capito però è leggermente difficile
fermi un attimo si perfetto ok fattaccio
fatta preso tre giovani ragazzi e pian
piano niente una sega proprio no bravo
bravo di morire in modo atroce
ok e come posso faccio da essere
superman non è possibile come faccio
come fa un essere umano a fare un salto
così sì no no no no no ho già detto no
no no no io mi dimentico porca [ __ ]
le cose reano piano si indietro mio dio
mio dio che cosa cosa ho fatto
cosa ho fatto per salvarla premi 30
volte la cosa mi dice che non è con non
sarà così facile però proviamoci così
tanto per 4 3 2 1 che cazzo ci fa
chiamare il suo gioco
anche qua devi rompere il cazzo fammi
capire ovviamente sta cosa mi volete
dire che era quello quello di quello
nascosto non ditemi che ce l'ho fatta
senza saperlo perché potrebbe esultare
sì l'ho fatta ho vinto sì sì sì
mio dio ragazzi ho trovato per botta di
culo sommesso non so quanto prendi le
armi e non tornare mai indietro la bene
dalla ci prova vai così ho preso una
pistola e vabbè ma non siete stronzi lo
stesso mi fanno il culo uguale quindi
non cambia niente perché è passato un
cavallo che gioca si fa sempre più
strano ogni volta che l'ho già ma perché
è il suicido primo è l'app india e
allora siete strani e mi fanno le
indicazioni sbagliate fantastic mi si
trovano le pistole
siccome mi saranno neanche le cose
[ __ ] ce la posso fare se si è
capito bene non mi servivano neanche la
pista non mi ha preso ragazzi ma ok no
non mi stanno colpendo maledizione ma sì
sì no no dài dài abbiamo capito che la
sorella che è brutta sì che cazzo il
tasto jump si è spostato si spostano i
tasti adesso questa cosa meno che merda
non posso che gareggiando perché si
sposta ok solo cliccato tu ca [ __ ]
difficilissima
allora che la minaccia posso fare non è
che i pc ok ok no no no no ma vedi che
sei brutto proprio nel cervello no no no
no no dai
ok perfetto l'ho fatta prometto che c'è
qualcosa per cento ti ringrazio dio
accendiamo un cero perché è assurdo non
fare la forza al milan lo sapevo capito
o no cielo quasi
piano che lancia sacher [ __ ] meno to
peace e cioè un bagno giusto non è
giusto truelove vero amore certo ci
mancherebbe che ho beccato uno sbagliato
potrei incazzarmi in modo violento tra
pochi secondi che qualcuno mi spiega
corso cosa o che cosa ha dato io non
vedo il personaggio quindi non so non so
saltare niente non c'è verso se sei fan
calmi film di angel of grass ok ragazzi
perché ci sono due pira cammelli fare lo
salta no sono stronzi sti cosi fare
ragazzi non ho capito cos'è eccolo qui
potete potente pup almeno adesso ok ma
anche qualcuno che ha voglia di
spiegarmela sta cosa perché merda noni e
sono morto come si fa l'unica no ma
[ __ ] dobbiamo cliccare sto schifo
fantastico grazie marì marì grazie
perfetto led e funzione gardev arriverà
alla fine di sto potuto livelli in
qualche modo già si può fare non ci si
può fare tutto scherzando qualche mondo
ciardi voli non ci arrivo adesso a [ __ ]
le uova a perfetto no mi ha chiesto che
esce e muoio lo stesso perché quando
quando non c'è verso
ma neanche a morire ok su uka uka ancora
uno no perché grazie molto gentile
ragazzi devo vedere un attimo il razzo
nel culo quindi quindi quindi muoio ho
capito lo so lo so ci avrei scommesso
ragazzi devo
devo morire in borsa che a marcare un
razzo fantasma poi esce qualcosa lo
sapevo no no no che cazzo
ok perché ciò fa sì ragazzi sto facendo
non so come perfetto si grande di sotto
di sotto casa cucù cucù secolo skip da
dove minchia 6 spuntato cosa dovrei fare
di precedere no no ho capito ho capito
lo saltare sul cubo però sono stupido è
una cosa fattibile ragazzi mette un
pochettino ma ci riesco perfetto già
fatta già fatta
se livello all'ultimo del so cos'è cos'è
sta roba è l'ultimo prima di passare
agli altri livelli quindi dovrebbe
essere difficile come se gli altri non
lo fossero
cosa faccio adesso si no no sì se dovevo
cliccarli condito fantastico ha
funzionato ragazzi ci ho messo in mezzo
no perché non morivano venir ma va bene
così ragazzi basta mi fermo qui perché
sto e sto esaurendo giuro sono
contentissimo ragazzi di aver trovato un
gioco così meraviglioso per ipad come
venuta l'idea di iniziare a registrare
con l'ipad
mi piace il drone quindi ragazzi
continuano nel prossimo episodio fatemi
sapere se volete che lo contini
ovviamente solo continuiamo favino
continuare problema iscrivetevi che cosa
ne pensate nei commenti comunque agazzi
servito mi è piaciuto ma solito al
momento mi piace contro fatto velocista
parte dai giovani facebook che come noi
villa trovate la descrizione senza loro
istinti scrivete noi ci vediamo al
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi